aj you're playing monday morning
quarterback with your career
let's say you're looking at your life
was it 10 years ago when you came to la
as a freelance cinematographer what do
you know there's that standard thing
what do you wish you knew then
that you know now
the things that i know now i don't think
i could have known then i think it took
a lot of experience and a lot of
gigs to get that knowledge and i'm glad
that it took that
because i feel like it's more ingrained
in my
you know
style and just like instinct something
that i
had to earn by working so hard for so
long
um
i think i had a blind confidence when i
was younger that helped me kind of push
through things that might have been
uh discouraging or
uh would have held me back if i dwelled
on it too long
and uh i'm thankful for that uh i think
i think that got me past a certain point
where now i can i feel like i'm
confident enough in my ability that
i feel like i really truly feel like i
could do just about anything that i was
asked to do as a cinematographer and i
i'm excited by challenges and things
that are tough now because it's
you know it's new it's fresh it keeps me
excited about what i do
and i i i still feel the same way as i
did back then because i was constantly
learning new things and i think
i think
there really isn't a whole lot that i
would have wished i knew back then that
i didn't
know i mean a lot of it was already kind
of doing it was just more like
social stuff like things that you had to
be careful of
i wish that i knew a little more about
how crazy la was when i first moved here
because it was just it was tough for a
little while i came from a place where
people were very nice to you and they
say hi all the time and
there's no ulterior motives there and uh
it kind of threw me for a loop for a
little while i guess for the first year
or two i was out here but
i think i also needed that i think and
you needed to experience that
order to get the kind of resilience that
you need to be able to push through
so i suppose i wish i would have known
that earlier but
if i didn't know it earlier i wouldn't
have earned it
i guess that makes sense
you